Hi zusammen! Heute vereine ich mal zwei eurer Wünsche in einem Video!
Und zwar fragen mich immer wieder Leute aus der Kikimunity: "Kannst du mal was veganes machen?"
und "Kannst du mal Low Carb Gerichte zeigen?".
Und heute mache ich ein veganes Low Carb Gericht, ganz einfach!
Wir machen heute eine Brokkoli-Lauch-Curry Pfanne mit Blumenkohlreis.
Blumenkohlreis ist eine tolle Alternative zu normalem kohelydratreichem Reis, das zeige ich euch nachher.
Wir machen jetzt zuallererst unser Curry und dafür gehe ich jetzt einmal rüber zu meiner beschichteten Pfanne
wo ich jetzt zuallererst Kokosöl erhitzen werde und dann presse ich da Knoblauch rein und dann dünste ich das so ein bisschen an.
[Kiki]"Und dann, und dann, und dann!" Das habe ich jetzt ziemlich oft gesagt!
[Hamza] "Und anschließend" kannst du auch sagen!
Anschließend, genau!
So, jetzt gebe ich zum Knoblauch noch eine besondere Zutat, und zwar - das könnt ihr total variabel entscheiden -
Ich habe heute von Like Meat Like Chicken.
Das ist aus Bio Soja und das hat mir beim letzen Mal schon so gut geschmeckt
und als das Team von Like Meat dann gefragt hat, ob ich mir noch was Leckeres einfallen lassen möchte,
habe ich natürlich sofort Ja gesagt weil ich feier die Produkte!
Alles, was die anbieten ist 100%ig vegan und glutenfrei
Und beim Like Chicken ist es so: Es sieht aus wie Hähnchen.
100%ig schmeckt es nicht nach Hähnchen aber es kommt dem schon sehr nahe
und ich finde gerade wenn man mal so vegane Alternativen einbauen möchte, ist das auf jeden Fall eine top Geschichte.
Und daher gebe ich das jetzt noch mit zum Öl und brate das so ungefähr 3-4min noch da mit an.
Ich sag ja: Echt lecker! Mmh!
Also ich muss echt sagen: Wir sind jetzt keine Veganer aber auch wir versuchen natürlich, immer wieder mal so vegane Tage mit einzubauen.
[Hamza] Neues auszuprobieren!
[Kiki] Neues auszuprobieren!
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen: Der Trend geht ja auch so in Richtung immer weniger Fleisch.
Obwohl offen gestanden Hamza und ich trotzdem Fleischliebhaber sind aber wenn, dann muss es wirklich gutes Fleisch sein.
Dass wir wirklich trotzdem mal so Alternativen ausprobieren.
Und wenn ihr mal im Supermarkt an Like Meat vorbeikommt, dann probiert es gerne mal aus. Klare Empfehlung meinerseits!
Ich mache jetzt hiermit weiter. Das Coole ist: Das Rezept ist wirklich sehr variabel!
Ich gebe jetzt direkt mal Tomatenmark mit dazu und dann kommt mein Gemüse schon mit in die Pfanne.
Ich hab heute Brokkoli und Lauch genommen.
Was würde jetzt noch gehen? Zum Beispiel Möhren, Paprika..
Eigentlich alles, worauf ihr Lust habt denn das wird gleich sowieso alles in der Soße gegart.
[Hamza] Was ist das?
[Kiki] Kokosmilch!
[Hamza] Ahh, Kokosmilch!
So! So, das ist ganz normal. Das verflüssigt sich jetzt, da braucht ihr euch keine Sorgen machen!
So, jetzt noch Currygewürzmischung dazu.
So, das Gemüse jetzt 5min lang in der Soße köcheln lassen und ich mache jetzt schon mal meinen Blumenkohlreis.
Das Ganze geht super, super schnell, deswegen muss ich mich jetzt fast schon beeilen damit ich beides noch warm servieren kann.
Ihr benötigt ganz einfach einen Blumenkohl. Den müsst ihr nicht vorgaren sondern einfach nur so ein bisschen mixen
damit es eine reisähnliche Form bekommt oder zumindest die Größe von Reis.
Und das gebe ich jetzt in meinen Topf, - hier habe ich etwas Kokosöl erhitzt -
salze das, pfeffer das Ganze und dann ist es auch schon fertig.
Und optional könnt ihr noch ein bisschen Schwarzkümmel am Ende dazugeben.
So, und fertig ist unser veganes Mittagessen!
Also ich empfehle es euch wirklich, das mal auszuprobieren,
egal ob ihr euch vegan ernährt oder nicht!
Und falls ihr weitere Wünsche habt in Bezug auf vegan oder Low Carb oder generell Mittagessen,
dann schreibt's mir unbedingt unten in die Kommentare!
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung
und ansonsten freue ich mich über euer Feedback, wie euch dieses Rezept gefallen hat.
Und dann würde ich mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!